Crystal's fiance Whitney has finally  arrived on the farm 29 year old bachelor  winner Whitney Bischoff has finally  joined fiance crystals on his Arlington  Iowa farm The Bachelor documented the  whole experience on Instagram Wednesday  sharing this snapshot captioned her  first day planting corn hashtag farmer  and training then it was tractor time  the 33 year old then put Whitney behind  the wheel in row she's a natural  chris has had quite the whirlwind year a  proposal Dancing with the Stars and just  being booted off this week but the  farmer is happy to be back in his home  state posting this pic that read so good  to be back and another saying my morning  commute sure don't miss that LA traffic  he's got his girl he's got his farm what  more could a guy need do you think these  two will last let us know on twitter  using the hashtag ET now